[Música]
que ven en esta imagen
algunos me podrán decir que ven algún
tipo de órgano del cuerpo humano
otros podrán decir
queda en algún tipo de ágil
mexicano o peruano pero para mí esta
imagen tiene mucha fuerza
hace un poco más de 11 años se me
ocurrió una loca idea
emprender una empresa
productora de tomate deshidratado
envasada en aceite y con hierro
la peor idea del mundo que se me puede
ocurrir
si nosotros hace 11 años hubiéramos
contratar a un experto hubiéramos
he hecho un estudio de mercado de
factibilidad sobre si el negocio era
rentable o era factible les aseguro que
hubiera salido que no
pero con mi locura si en base a nada
realmente
de 22 años en un lugar de 5 x 5 y con
400 dólares en el bolsillo
les dije a mi padre
un día
que iba a renunciar a mi trabajo
mi padre mi madre me dice que está bien
mi hijo este era mi primer trabajo ya
que te va a dedicar que empresas has
pensado hacer y le digo voy a colocar
una empresa que de hirata tomate para
vender aquí en bolivia
y que es el tomate hidratado no lo
conocía
había comprado en la única tienda
naturista que había en santa cruz le
invite lo probaron
y me dicen pero como se comentó
lo puedes usar en ensaladas le digo lo
haces un sandwich es buenísimo
y me dicen no creo que se venda para
otra cosa
con mi locura lo primero que hice fue
hacer un horno un horno hechizo un horno
de thor es sencillo calor abajo a gas
entonces con el horno ya me tocaba
producir
con lo poco que pude averiguar en
internet porque hace 11 años la
información no era como ahora ha crecido
muchísimo ahora uno coloca tomate
deshidratado y te sale mucha información
de cualquier cosa entonces
empiezo a las 5 de la tarde y en el
horno 50 kilo de tomate corto el tomate
de pulpo meto al horno yo no sabía que
que duraba 12 horas del secado en ese
horno que había hecho o sea que con el
proceso y todo termine más o menos 8 de
la mañana el deshidratado del del tomate
tomé el tomate lo puse en un balde con
hierba bueno lo puse en un balde con
hierbas para que le dé sabor
y al otro día lo saqué el tomate y lo
envase
en un tupper citó lo envase en un tupper
bueno dije me salieron 50 unidades de
tomates dilatados digo que hago voy a
regalar a mis familiares y a mis amigos
que lo prueben el producto y después me
vayan haciendo el boca a boca no
entonces los 50 regales 30 más o menos
fui le dejé a mis familiares les de
algunos amigos que ya trabajaban algunas
empresas petroleras para que me dan el
boca a boca y listo ahora esperar que me
pidan al otro día me llamó una amiga
y me dice jorge le salió algo blanco a
tu tomate mes
algo blanco lejos pero que puede ser no
mejor nivel este no había los celulares
para sacar fotos no se podía enviar
fotos hace 11 años me voy a su casa me
entrega el envase lo abro y lleno de una
lama blanca
ese fue el día que conocí a la bacteria
parece lógico parece obvio pero yo no lo
sabía yo no soy ingeniero en alimentos
entonces no sabía qué fue lo que hice
investigue con lo poco que había
investigo un poco tenés que tener un
poco más de higiene tenés que ver tener
otros cuidados y también me voy a un que
lo que pienso bueno pensabas pensar 'si
este a un lugar donde venden aditivos
alimenticios los conservantes son los
que solucionan todo digamos en mentiras
me voy al lugar en la persona que me
atiende muy bien ni siquiera me quiere
vender el producto y me dice por qué no
lo colocas los tomates en aceite que
estén allí abajo mes que lógico no el
aceite y vinagre conservantes naturales
hasta mi bolita me lo ha dicho entonces
a retoma te lo pongo en aceite y me dura
30 días refrigerado el producto belleza
yo con esto ya estamos empiezo a vender
boca a boca a los amigos parientes pero
los parientes y amigos no comen tomates
hidratado todos los días no o sea que yo
logré solamente vender 50 unidades
semanales es lo que vendía con harto
esfuerzo
mientras tanto ya veía también que
habían personas que yo no conocía que me
llamaban quiere decir que el boca a boca
estaba resultando habían este amigos de
mis amigos me llamaban y me decían este
joven me puede traer el tomate hidratado
claro ya sería lo mandó al muchacho se
iba yo y lo lleva del tomate
bueno entonces mi siguiente mi siguiente
paso era lograr trabajar por lo menos de
lunes a viernes tener una jornada de
lunes a viernes por eso lo hacía el
lunes y después no tenía más jornada
entonces me voy a probar con un
supermercado uno pequeño que tiene que
tiene tres sucursales en la ciudad me
voy con mi tomatito subo a la encargada
de compra lo ve el tomate y tuve mucha
suerte lo agarré el tomate y me dice yo
conozco este producto es mucha suerte
algunos meses lo conozco porque lo he
visto afuera y la verdad que me interesa
mañana venir con estos órdenes meses así
de sencillo el otro día recojo las
órdenes y me había pedido 12 unidades
para cada sucursal 212 tomatito feliz ya
tenía 36 más no se podía vender semanal
entonces casi dos días de producción lo
produzco corto el tomate todo meto al
horno al otro día voy lo entrego al
supermercado lo colocó en el
supermercado me dan el sector de
verduras porque no tenía ni idea dónde
vive el tomate seco me dan y me dice le
digo la de verdura por favor me lo
cuidan y tomatitos miran están acá y lo
dejó bien al otro día no tenía que
producir entonces me voy a ver cómo se
había vendido
entro a la primera sucursal y empiezo a
contarnos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 2
entró a la segunda sucursal y empiezo a
contar 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 11 2 a la
tercera sucursal digo estas sucursales
en un lugar donde vive en la clase
social un poco más alta mis productos
gourmet entonces seguro que ha salido
uno de ellos entró 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 12
respiro
bueno el primer día de uno no sea vender
el primer día hay que darle un poquito
más de tiempo voy el segundo día a la
primera sucursal y cuento 2
la segunda sucursal cuento 1 2 3 4 5 6 2
a la tercera sucursal
tercer día voy entró primera sucursal 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 2 segunda sucursal 3 562
tercera sucursal 1 próximo 12 cuarto día
voy
12 12 y 2 una semana después de que
había hecho la entrega voy entró a las
tres sucursales 12 12 y 2 no se había
vendido un solo tomate seco ni siquiera
para decir ya pues alguien éste lo
agarró el tomate digamos no para probar
no se vendió ni uno
es la oportunidad
bueno ahí tenemos opción tirar la toalla
o se le busca una solución era lógico
que no se iba a vender todos tenía razón
porque no había un hábito de consumo no
se consumía el producto nadie lo conocía
entonces pienso que se puede hacer yo sé
que es bueno el tomate yo lo comía es
rico tiene buen sabor como no le va a
gustar a la gente eso es determinación
le digo
y pienso un ajustador a alguien que lo
invite pero no tengo plata para
contratarlas y que la mía es la hermana
de un amigo del mejor amigo lo llamó el
mejor amigo le digo oye la puedo llamar
a tu hermana para que le guste tenía 17
años me dice claro llamar a la llamó a
su hermana y le digo quieres trabajar en
el mercado degustando tomate claro me
dice es te amo no pero hay un problema
leo no te puedo pagar todavía tengo que
esperar a que me paguen supermercado
claros me dices no no hay problema no te
producto no te preocupes objeto meses
bueno
la cosa es vamos vamos al sur mercado
con una galletita el tomate seco y
empieza invitar
la dejo vuelvo a las 8 de la noche
porque es de 48 a las 8 de la noche a
ver
como le había ido
y los había vendido los 12 los 12 tomate
seco los vendió en cuatro horas empecé a
hacerla rotar de supermercados
supermercados ella trataba y vendía y
vendía y vendía los del supermercado me
decían tú tomate se vende como pan
caliente
y feliz yo pensando ya vienen los
millones
y la cosa es que ya con eso y con y con
esfuerzo ella ella estuvo degustando
tomate seco un año y medio un año y
medio sin parar día a día ella hizo
conocer el tomate deshidratado la ciudad
ella creó el hábito del consumo de
tomate deshidratado que no existía el
hábito consumo entonces
pensando ya tenía dos días de producción
y dio este me dio en esto de todo esto
que pasaba mi madre como me quiere mucho
le decía todas mis tías que me den
trabajo y que y que ya algo no en serio
yo le decía mamá de molestar yo estoy
haciendo las cosas en serio ya estoy
trabajando y me venían ofertas de tías
de parientes que tenían que tenía una
empresa entonces ya digo necesito más
día de producción tenía dos tenía que
completar los cinco
y ahora me voy a ir al supermercado más
grande de bolivia
me voy todo canchero como tomatito
se lo entregó al encargo de compra lo
mira le falta código barrantes hoy tenía
razón le faltaba que llevar voy no tenía
plata para hacer una etiqueta de nuevo a
una etiqueta chica le colocó una
etiqueta de colgar atrás se lo presentó
y me dice
no tiene presentó seguridad mes se abre
y tenía razón
voy busco el plástico es que es un termo
contra y vélez no lo conocía veo en el
supermercado que hay
busco una empresa de plástico que me
pueda vender la mínima cantidad encontré
una que me vendió un pucho que tenía
olvidado ahí lo tomé pistola termo con
una pistola de calor fuck arriba voy se
lo presentó
todavía se todavía se abre está muy
débil el precinto
no te lo puedo recibir después entonces
pongo un termo contra y bleu entero a
todo el tupper donde iba el tomate lo
pongo entero en termo contra y bleu y
voy y se lo presente
agarre el tomate lo mira ya está el
precinto bien no lo vuelcan y le cae una
pequeña gota de aceite
por el envase
no es hermético mes se derrama no te lo
puedo recibir
yo salí ya mí sin experiencia sin nada
no tenía idea de qué hacer y hablando
con mi primo que tampoco tenía idea de
nada el menor que mí me dice yo le dio
mucho y no puedo no puedo ingresarlo
este supermercado tengo este problema me
dice que derrama y la verdad que cierra
nada bueno y él me dice y por qué no lo
pone al vacío
en estas bolsas pero esta máquina de
hacer carísima
no pero estas máquinas caseras meses las
pósters que son baratas bueno voy cien
dólares me costó la maquinita viene con
las bolsas incluso puse el tomate seco
en la bolsita aceite las hierbas y el
aceite en la maquinita envasado al vacío
lo puse en el tupper cerrado y con el
termo contra y bleu
parecía un búnkeres me voy
a presentarlo
lo toman lo abren lo destapa lo sacan
mira el sello lo aprieta
pero residió mes
pasa mañana a buscar tus órdenes
paso al otro día y en la suma de todos
los supermercados me habías pedido 300
unidades 300 para mí eran seis días de
trabajo más los dos ya tenía todo las
órdenes bueno estas son tres simples
ocasiones
de las centenares de veces que pude
haber tirado la toalla
y decidí seguir
si ustedes me preguntan qué se necesita
para emprender algo primero se necesita
mucho trabajo mucho trabajo
y después
e iniciar lo empezarlo
no importa las capacidades que tenga ese
momento las capacidades las puedes
conseguir no importa el conocimiento que
tengas ese momento el conocimiento lo
vas a aprender no importa el dinero que
tengas
va a aparecer el dinero lo vas a
conseguir
haz lo que tienes con lo que tengas y
donde estés
no sé si han escuchado alguna vez esta
corriente que dice del corriente pero de
salud del secreto el secreto de la vida
no lo mandas onda
al universo y vienen y te devuelven o
dice que si vos querés un auto cero
kilómetro con auto honda civic la marca
incluso la pone y empiezas a pensar y
pensar quiero ese auto quiere ese auto
que te va a parecer el auto burrera
en la peor barrera que hay todo se
consigue levantándose de las nalgas
yendo a trabajar yendo a conseguirlo si
es real lo que es pero lo tienes que
conseguir tiene que muerte
para emprender algo
hay que saber que la determinación y la
perseverancia son más importantes que la
inteligencia y que la habilidad
entonces me diría jorge
y la inteligencia no es importante si es
importante y seguro que ayuda pero te
aseguro que alguien muy inteligente si
no tiene determinación y perseverancia
no puede conseguir su vestido
la habilidad acaso no es importante
claro que es importante y ayuda pero
también les aseguro que hasta el mejor
war the fool o en cualquier actividad
aparte de la habilidad en el que entrena
más que todos
yo hoy día los invito a cultivar la
determinación y perseverancia en todos
los aspectos su vida este es un simple
ejemplo de de un emprendimiento
empresarial pero esto se puede aplicar
en tu familia con tu pareja en cualquier
objetivo que quieras conseguir sea
pequeño
algo tan simple como tal vez cambiar
hábitos malos que tengamos hábitos de
alimentación algún hábito físico
mejoramiento físico
tenemos que aplicar la determinación
tenemos que aplicar conscientemente la
determinación confiar en nosotros mismos
y tenernos fe ser positivo se necesita
y aplicar conscientemente la
perseverancia saber que cada error que
vamos cometiendo nos acerca más al
objetivo que queremos
muchas gracias por la atención
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah